it's almost as though the Psychedelic
thing is a mind which surrounds you and
knows yourself better than you do and
the the open doorway or the the
membrane to another dimension is like
setting up a metaphor that you can
understand for what is about to happen
to you the the weirdest instance of that
that I think I've ever heard of
it happened to me and it was that I had
been given some DMT to try and I smoked
it and nothing much seemed to happen
and so then I smoked some more and I
closed my eyes and concentrated on the
hallucinations and nothing much seemed
to happen and then after a moment I saw
water going past my eyes right here and
I pulled back and as I pulled back I saw
that the water was from a water fountain
in a recessed little Alabaster
Alcove sort of thing and then as I saw
more of the hallucination I saw that the
floor there were three steps up and it
was carpeted in very soft red material
and there was red flocking on the
wallpaper around this water fountain and
I was having this what the you know what
is this and then I turned around and
there was a heavy curtain 90 degrees to
my right that I hadn't seen this heavy
red spinach green velvet curtain and as
I pushed my way through it I was in a
huge theater in a DMT trip was happening
on the screen and I just melted down
onto my knees and was Swept Away by this
thing but there had been this really
weird
interfacing where it was presented as an
art deco theater and the water fountain
right outside the main viewing area
weird
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign